yo jelly roll told told me about some
sort of [__] tent or something that was
going on that's dope what's wrong with
that nothing's wrong with that there
should be some in several locations that
I we would love wait a minute that's
actually a [__] great idea a [__]
tent we can provide like six tents on
the ground big red tents and light them
up all red right yeah and be like and
you go in there and it's just all lavish
and clean a place you go in there [__]
you know you're in a wet tent you know
what I'm saying mosquitoes and [__] you
boys are right outside the nylon you
know what I mean you can go away to the
[__] tent you know what I'm saying you
guys for a small fee oh yeah like like a
little and then there's just like you
know willing lovelies in there you know
cuz all we're getting is a tense
consenting willing allegedly allegedly
consenting juglets I don't know what
that's actually dope like that's
actually a dope idea [__] not a terrible
idea